Ja, guck mal, vor 4 Jahren haben wir mit Laura was gebaut.
Ja, vor 4 Jahren haben wir was damit gebaut. Ja, habe ich auch schon ohne Stream
gemacht. Aber ich habe aktuell nichts im Einsatz, was Laura verwendet.
Nein, habe ich mir nicht gekauft, aber ich werde es auf jeden Fall spielen. Sind wir noch überlegen,
ob ich nicht vielleicht lieber sogar auf nem Emulator spielen soll, wenn das gut funktioniert.
Ich find's, auch wenn man's gekauft hat, überhaupt nicht verwerflich,
es auf nem Emulator zu spielen.
Die Switch ist halt schon ein bisschen in die Jahre gekommen jetzt.
Naja, was ist hier los, Mix steht auch im Titelshort drin!
Du hast den Prime benutzt, that's nice, danke schon für den Prime-Sub.
Oh, ich guck' gerade mal, wen haben wir denn hier noch? Wen hab' ich denn noch übersehen?
Puzzle-Master hat resubscribed. xgholomixx hat resubscribed.
Wir können zwei Sachen machen. Entweder ihr habt irgendwelche spannenden
Themen, Questions oder irgendwas. Wir können uns auch ein paar ITNews Sachen
angucken oder noch ein paar Videos hier aus der langen Watch History.
Ansonsten, was gibt's Spannendes? Diese Woche ist ein Feiertag also nächste Woche
ist ein Feiertag, ich glaub der Donnerstag wenn ich nicht ganz falsch
schlage... Guck mal wie Kacke der Windows Kalender ist. Der zeigt nicht mal Feiertage an.
Ich glaube das hier ist ein Feiertag nächste Woche.
Das heißt, ich muss tatsächlich eh nur eins zwei drei Tage arbeiten ja Feiertage
WTF? Ja viel besser. Jetzt aber die Musik zu leise. Kacke. So ist es okay.
Das heißt das wären 3,8 Arbeitstage. Krass oder? Aber das in 5 Jahren.
Das heißt das wären 3,8 Arbeitstage Krass oder? Aber das in 5 Jahren
Business Enterprise Umfeld, ist das eine realistische Sache die oft da werden Sachen
echt gerne aufgeblätter so nach dem Motto eigentlich ne Sache von 2-3 Tagen sich mal
intensiv damit beschäftigen Das Problem ist, dass du vor lauter Müden und Kontext Switchen
im Kopf, kaum 2-3 Tage am Stück hast, dann kann es am Ende durchaus mal 2-3 Wochen dauern
Ist leider im Enterprise Umfeld so, was auch der Grund ist, warum viele großen Unternehmen
so wahnsinnig ineffektiv sind, weil die unter anderem zuviel müden und zu viel kleinteilig
Sachen an alle leute verteilen sodass du permanent am umdenken bist zwischen unterschiedlichen
Tasks Das ist eigentlich das was Produktivität
92 bei 74 aber nicht mal so fett wie 107
107,5
hast du nach der Ausbildung vom Physi eine
Weiterbildung gemacht? ne warum ich habe
ganz normal gearbeitet
meine Weiterbildung genug?
du meinst jetzt ob ich irgendwelche
du meinst jetzt ob ich irgendwie keine
ahnung noch noch Zertifikate und so
zeug gemacht habe?
nee habe ich nicht. das einzige
Zertifikat was ich habe ist ein CCNA
und das ist noch von der Ausbildung.
das ist wahrscheinlich schon längst
abgelaufen. glaub ich ginge nur drei oder
fünf Jahre. außerdem juckt das niemand ob man
CCNA hat oder nicht. jeder hat einen CCNA
und so kompliziert ist es auch nicht
und da Cisco Netzwerkequipment gehört
jetzt auch nicht zum täglichen
Aufgabenfeld von jedem also ist es
relativ irrelevant ob ich den habe
oder nicht ansonsten
habe ich nicht. ich habe ein paar
Schulungemacht also ich habe einen Azure
ich habe irgend so ein paar Azure Kurse
gemacht also Kurse meine ich jetzt nicht
also ich habe angefangen mit C Sharp
damals und python 2.3 oder 2.2
oder was auch immer damals aktuell war
so ein dickes graues python Buch und ich
habe dann nach einer weile angefangen
mich ein bisschen mit mit C Sharp
.NET und Windows Desktop
Anwendung auseinander zu setzen weil
ich fand es damals irgendwie
spannend Windows Dev Studio Anwendungen zu
machen und ich habe das mit
C Sharp Buch damals gelernt
allerdings nicht mit der 2002
edition sondern mit der ...keine Ahnung
2003 edition oder so
also ich weiß als ich angefangen habe
mit .NET damals da war .NET 2
.NET Framework 2 gerade ganz aktuell
neu und super advances Scheiss mit
generic's und sowas das dürfte so 2003
irgendwie in dem dreh rum gewesen sein
und Ausbildung habe ich erst Jahre
später gemacht also es hat mich damals
schon interessiert und ich bin
auch der Meinung, dass jeder
Anwendungsentwickler sich ein bisschen
damit beschäftigen sollte wie es
sieht aus mit cloud architektur, wie es
sieht ein bisschen aus mit Linux mit
den betreibenden Anwendungen die man
gebaut hat ja mit den bereitstellen von
Datenbanken Message Queues und
sonstigen Geschichten und jeder Admin
egal ob Windows oder Linus oder auch
jeder Cloutarchitekt oder hast du das
nicht gesehen sollte sich ein bisschen
mit Anwendungsentwicklungen und
Programmieren beschäftigen
ist einfach von unschätzbarem Vorteil
wenn man sich besser so quasi weil man
dann auch irgendwelche sozialen Meetings
hat und sich überlegen muss wie
machen wir das jetzt am besten von der
Architektur, dass man sich ein
bisschen dann reinversetzen kann in die
jeweils andere seite und weiß ok was
könnt es da für probleme geben und
natürlich muss man auch sagen
Anwendungsentwickler reden auch viel
lieber Klartext oder reden auch viel
viel lieber mit jemand wo sie
merken der hat ein bisschen Ahnung davon
wie es ist sowas zu programmieren und
Admins reden auch lieber mit einem
Anwendungsentwickler, der ein bisschen
Ahnung davon hat wie es ist Linux zu
benutzen
das ist das ist dass da kommt man sich
das hab ich gesehen dass es keine Bash
Completion gibt. ich war bis dazu faul
Bash Completion einzubauen, weil ich
nicht weiß wie Bash Completion
funktioniert. ZSH Completion
konnte ich einfach copy pasten und ein
bisschen anpassen
ich hab keine Ahnung wie so eine bash
Completion aussehen muss
wobei der richtige Q-Chat bräuchte ja
sowas
Ne!
Kein Stream
Bei der Ausbildung zum Physi hast du da viel Hardware beim PC dran gearbeitet ?
Ja,
Wobei nicht wirklich Hardware beim PC, das kann man so nicht sagen
Es ist jetzt nicht so als hätte ich da viel Festplatten eingebaut
oder irgendwelche Desktop PCs aufgebaut
Aber ja ich habe in der Ausbildung tatsächlich sehr viel mit Hardware gemacht
Allerdings mit Enterprise Business Server Hardware
Ich war täglich in unterschiedlichsten Rechenzentren in Frankfurt unterwegs
Sweeeet
So und ich, ich war immer als erster Star und da habe ich frei willig gesagt ich macht einfach Rundgang
In jedem unserer Rechenzentren
Es klingt jetzt mehr als, es waren drei Stück ja
Eins im, eins, also eins im Keller
Noch eins im Keller
Und eins im, ach da ist der achten Stock oder sowas
So und
Ich konnte euch damals sagen
Ich bin ja immer im dunklen, genau das ist das was ich sagen wollte, ich bin ja immer im dunklen durch die Rechenzentren gelaufen morgens
Also ich habe nie die Lichte angemacht da drinnen
Weil ich finde das hat irgendwie so ne nette Stimmung gehabt
Im dunklen Rechenzentrum rumzulaufen
Wahrscheinlich ist das gegen jegliche Arbeitsschutzvorschriften gewesen oder sowas
Da musstest du wahrscheinlich, durftest du nur bei Licht laufen und sowas
Wobei ich hab da eine Sache gelernt beim Provider noch
Runter auf dem Fußfeld, du hast keine Sicherheitsschuhe an,Leute ich kann euch sagen
Dem ist ein Fuß, der ist dran gewesen, noch und das ist auch wieder geheilt, aber der konnte zwei Wochen nicht laufen
Ich meine, was wird so n Ding, Jett was meint ihr?
Ich weiß es jetzt wirklich nicht aus dem Kopf genau
Was wird so ein Ding vollbeladen wiegen?
30 Kilo
Die Alten hatten die Ja auch noch noch fest platten, dass wir hinter allem SSD ist, wie er gern 5 oder so gucken ja so ein Ding
Gang 6
So ein ding hier war das genau so ein teil dem da auf den fuß gefallen
30 kilo
Ich weiß ich würde sauce mal raten
Ich weiß jetzt mal raten
Ja
zumindest
Ich bin immer ich bin immer im dunklen morgens durch rechnet durch rechner um gelaufen
Und ich konnte euch damals sagen es jetzt wirklich also ungelogen. Ja, ich konnte euch damals sagen
Wenn nicht dass ich hätte, euch sagen können hätten wir uns davon gekannt
Welche led
Nicht so leuchtet wie gewöhnlich
Und ich war damit nicht nur war nur warnen leds wie lüfter ist kaputt auf orange
Ja, also ich war nach so oft morgens ich. Hab mir das alles genaus
Ich kann euch wirklich sagen wenn irgendwie an der stelle ein neues system eingebaut wurde habe ich sofort gesehen da steht irgendwas anderes
Und die rechtenzentren waren jetzt nicht mega groß aber auch nicht total klein
also die waren so
Mittel also das waren
Also das größte morgens wo ich durch bin das war nach squeal überlegen
Ich belege gerade wie viele wie viele rechter das waren
So 40 oder so 50 mit der 50 50 rekt vielleicht
Das war das größte wo ich morgens durch bin die anderen zwei waren kleiner das andere hatte irgendwie 20 30
Lax und das andere war me neithers hatte drei stück oder so
Und ich konnte wirklich sagen bei dem großen wo irgendwelche lampen unterschiedlich
Sind vom zum tag vorher
Also gut kannte ich mich bei uns im rechenszentrum aus
Und ich konnte euch auch sagen ob es normal war dass
Sie löfte in dieser ecke so laut waren oder nicht ja also
Da wusste in drousten zu dem zeitpunkt Buche wusste ich wirklich gut über unseren verzückt
Das war noch klug ich war damals auch noch dünner also dann doch dünner als als
No
Ne
Vielleicht ein bisschen dünner als jetzt ich habe ja ordnunglich abgenommen
vielleicht noch ein bisschen dünner als jetzt
weil der felix und ich wir waren die einzigen zwei die sie immer in die engen technik räume in den
Etagen verteilern geschickt haben weil wir die einzigen 2 waren die noch jung genug und dünn genug waren
um uns an allen switchen und kabeln vorbei zu krabbeln
Es gibt ein paar ausnahmen die gut gealtert sind
was aber auch hauptsächlich am style der games liegt
spiele die zur ihrer release zeit möglichst realistisch sein wollen sind meistens relativ schlecht gealtert
ich war sehr beeindruckt vom ersten FarCry und ich denke mal FarCry 1 ist tatsächlich eines der game
die noch ganz passabel gealtert sind für ihr
Für ihr release datum
Aber trotzdem an vielen stellen denke ich würde man auch heute
denken wenn man sich irgendwann das sieht vollkommen in Ordnung aus
ja aber an vielen stellen wird man sich auch angucken gerade im battles und sowas wenn man sich FarCry 1 anguckt wird manお
Man merkt einem das alte an und das ist 2004 das ist so die zeit ab der 3d spiele die auf realismus gemacht haben
Halbwegs spielbar sind heute noch
Fortbereit uns Zu
Mutation
Mit
Also ich würde sagen von
von so appealinges
Dürfte offen super nintendo kronerträger und Final Fantasy 6 wirklich eines der bushten gangs gewesen sein so zu JC RPG mäßig
Ja
Da moren finde ich ist nicht wirklich gut gehalt. Also mit mods vielleicht aber im original
Ich weiß nich
Es ist schon
Ja
Semigut gealt hat vielleicht ob livian geht dann schon voll klar
Hat er die em Crat ja hat wir hatten
Hatten wir
Ja, ich habe ich habe viele
Tickets aufgemacht damals bei IBM und hab gesagt hier wir brauchen neues Netzteil
Euren Lüfter neue Festplate war's auch immer
Und dann braucht man bei IBM. Leute wenn er jemals bei IBM ein Ticket aufmacht ganz wichtig denkt dran die FrueX Umar
Ohne nummer
Geht nix
Das ist so die die Inventar nummer bei IBM wenn ihr keine fraue numer habt
IBM fru genau die stadt die städter hier drauf gibt es bei IBM nix Fruex Nummer ist das aller wichtigste
Morgen Christian
Ja viel sie machen sehr viele verschiedene sachen
Ohne nummer
Das kann jemand erfahren
Einkaufen
Meinser Landstrasse 155
Interessante Frage
Das sind hochverfügbare Server viel komplexer als Normale server Im web Hosting
also
Server sind nicht dass du guard
Kallerstraße War
Ich auch schon in der clase war ich drinnen Aber da bin die kleine Straße hatte Ich dass es größer?
Gewesen der Kleine Strasse das Rechenzentrum aber das ist nicht Teil dieser Drei Rechenzentrum die ich meine wo ich täglich den Rundgang Gemacht
haben Kleine Straße, War Ich auch öfters drin ist und
in der kleine straße haben
wir Wir haben, wir Die Decke unfrist Packt weil der wenn der aufzug zu klein war
Und
Die
Leute die das gefahren haben
Trotz Wie zugenommen haben dass Sie aus dem fahrstuhl heraus gepresst haben das ist dann auch das Plastik abgesplittert oben vom storage und
sowas
Eines doch Die überlebt auch mit verkratzen decken
Ja
Ja also Es sind Ja Meistens Nicht wie sanft Es die hochverfügbar sind sondern Die Anwendungen auf den
die Du auf Den Laughter Laufen Lässt
Die Musste hochverfügbar Machen und Ja in der regel Kann. Man sagen Sehen hochverfügbare services
deutlich Komplexer Als Ein Single
Single Note Service
und
Wenn Du es nicht gescheit machst und wenn du nicht aufpasst kann es sogar Sein
dass du durch die für
du Quasi aus Fälle hast durch Deine hochverfügbarkeit
Konstruktion natürlich auch doof Du musst es machen sie wissen was du machst
Was in der Regel heißt in einem Cluster eigentlich immer drei nodes
Zwei nodes! Machen nur Probleme bei hochverfügbarkeit, das kann ich euch aus eigener Erfahrung sagen
Wisst ihr was das größte Problem ist, wenn du nicht drei Cluster nodes hast die ordentlich Netzwerk-technisch angebunden sind?
Chat
Wer ist vom Fach und oder Lernt Physik oder sonst was? Was ist das größte Problem
wenn du einen Cluster baust mit nur zwei nodes?
oder, der häufigste Fehler den du hast
Split brain, genau, ja so sieht es aus
Das heißt
Ja ihr geht alle in die gleiche richtung jet ich bin ich bin zufrieden mit euch
five header chet
Ja also es geht alles geht alles in die richtige richtung. Das problem ist, wenn du einen zwei node Cluster hast
Und es ruckelt eine technisch irgendwas oder
Es ist davor irgendwas kaputt, wie auch immer ja dass dann beide knoten
Relativ schnell denken
der andere ist kaputt und sie müssten jetzt master sein
Was dann dazu führt dass wenn du beispielsweise
Ips hast, die schwenken von einem auf den anderen node dass du auf einmal zwei master
Knoten hast die beide denken wir sind aktiv weil der andere Jahr, Weg ist
Und solche geschichten also dass das führt öffnet als man denkt zum problem
Das heißt wenn ein asatter macht dann müssten es drei note sein
Und die ganzen müssen netzt die mussten netzwerk technisch auch. So miteinander verbunden sein
Dass ein netzwerk ruckler in an irgendeiner stelle nicht dazu führt dass die durch sich alle auf einmal nicht mehr untereinander sehen
Also am besten auch irgendwie extra interconnect verbindungen oder sonstige geschichten
Ich keine ahlung wenn so ein ding runter gefallen wäre halt einfach mal ein auto wie ein auto vernichtet quasi
So extrem war es nicht dass sich die blinkrate morgens von einem server wusste aber
Also wenn es ganz ausgefallen war schon so nach dem motto normalerweise blinzt regelmäßig und jetzt blingt er wie
Gar nicht mehr oder ganz an schon aber so die sind also den intervall der blinkrate das hätte ich das hätte ich dir nicht sagen
können
Das war tunes shoe monitor ich noch
Könntest du mir sagen wenn ich die mein problem bei meinem notebook sagen würde was die ursachen die remote zu diagnostizieren ist meistens nicht gescheit möglich
Immer nur kann migrant schreiben vielleicht sind die leute wir so high iq was
Was wir wissen dass sie sind ob die idee dazu haben aber ich fürchten remote diagnose
Konstruktive nicht herstellen
Tour es ist immer der vergleich in mange musimeter
Was wir wissen dass sie sind ob die ideäre zu haben aber ich fürchte remote diagnose kann sie decken
Ja
Das stimmt wahrschreif drei ist gut gealtert
Das erste an die sind auch ganz brauchbar gealtert
Ja
Auch ein
spannendes
Ich hab einirm er ist earrings
Maine
platte
Das klingt ganz nach IBM
das ist wirklich IBM all die IBM, Webseite ist auch, so ekelig
Das ist so abartig
Gott
Nein Gott bitte nein nein und das ist schon die bisschen neue die alten war noch schlimmer
Was ist das für ein bescheues
Warum
Was ist das für eine bescheuerte Frage
Alter ich mach weder CSGAU noch mache ich glücksspiel Stream oder obs ich sagen steuerlich absetzen kann oder nicht
Ich würde ja tatsächlich sogar unter dem Strich noch minus machen weil ich und ich hab doch nicht mal was von
Ja die Logik verstehe ich auch nicht so ganz an dem Satz, aber das ist das ist eindeutig eindeutig Debate Ersatz
Das war jetzt auch ein bisschen verspätet oder?
Oder kann das sein, dass er gar keine Subscriptions mehr anzeigt?
Es funktioniert!
...